a century ago Argentina was one of the
10 richest countries in the world but it
is earned the dubious distinction of
being the only nation ever to regress to
developing country status since Araminta
or no tango a siempre a loner
Marco poco a Latino by either Argentina
has had a major economic crisis roughly
once every decade in the last half
century
so hyperinflation devaluations and IMF
bay lights have all become facts of life
in Latrobe eyes lolo momento de tocar
fondo even brain hacer esto se Thomas
era de candolle problema del Argentina
seen in 10 terrible are at the hosts
manage so what is it like living the
state of almost constant economic
turmoil and after signing up to the
biggest bailout package in the IMF's
history can Argentina finally break free
from a cycle of boom and bust
[Music]
mm and a team has tested Argentines
patients in September workers took to
the streets to protest inflation that
has soared above 40 percent a currency
crisis that has cut the pesos value in
half compared to the dollar and the
government's latest loan from the IMF
cheaper and SL Belarus Oregon Argentina
nada oin no Sierra know número como que
sigue Laguna can Argentina de novo here
no hace la cosa male lotro en el Epirus
el mejor para no La Salle in Kaimuki
Sierra president Mauricio Macri has been
applauded for his reforms to cut the
fiscal deficit in tackle inflation but
signs of a downward economic spiral are
all too familiar here volatility has
defined Argentina's recent history the
memories of the last severe crisis in
2001 are still fresh
[Music]
amita Chrissy Sharm el ganso bomb kasi
treinta Y Pico Janos nunca Alito's oppa
necesito Xian
well mendez at Rosa ZOA attack Sita a
colossal wound siren enters remember
saucer Marienthal a comprar cosas
Citarella para venir Agha before the
economic crisis of 2001
Louisa's taxi license was worth about
the same as a 500 square foot
one-bedroom apartment in Buenos Aires
but in 2002 after a three-year long
recession Argentina ended a decade-long
pegged to the u.s. dollar
bank deposits in Dexter dollars lost
more than 70 percent of their value
wiping out people's savings almost
overnight shelter mineral yendo lolly
sentient taxi in cuatro million dollar
is cuando su mejor momento al essential
taxes water
Cuarenta mil dólares para nada 104 molar
and B sorry II no solamente me Paso
Massino gala pasado
muchisimas antigua perdido muchas cosas
en si DM Luis was forced to return to
the family business at the san telmo
market where they have worked since they
have arrived as immigrants from Italy in
the together with his siblings and
mother they also run to help make ends
meet when they go second goal I see what
the mass is
robotics se acidemia kept insisting
guitarla a and C yeah well economy right
down
forgive me we see who I know or if that
tell me what I love are saying you know
what else is she gonna bring us a slight
now yeah even in a poor publisher no
wait a minute
bless the amateur no family have found
ways to survive repeated economic crises
but the country as a whole has been left
psychologically scarred in 2001 a lethal
cocktail of excessive state spending and
borrowing a flawed currency regime and
volatility in emerging markets led to
the catastrophic failure of an IMF
rescue program
Argentines have not forgotten the
grinding recession social chaos and
acute political instability of those
days the problem is that in Argentina
history has a way of repeating itself
this year the government turned the
International Monetary Fund for help
again they secured a fifty seven billion
dollar loan making it the biggest
bailout package in the IMF s history
cuando uno CBS in finance e amento le
key on dos opciones Oh Judy Ron pressed
a matado div estancia hacer una canción
fiscal mucho más rápida la vista moses
endo nosotros decidimos aku dear al
fondo puerto K value ahmo's que era la
mejor solution antennas de cuidado de la
sociedad Argentina
no no pro coupon recent volatility in
emerging markets triggered by rising US
interest rates and a looming trade war
with China
exposed the vulnerabilities of
Argentina's gaping fiscal and current
account deficits and when foreign
investors were no longer willing to lend
to Argentina the government was forced
to seek financial backing from the IMF
yet again los últimos II sent a nose
Largent inna to un promedio de FEC ante
in Teresa's de dos por ciento LPO tipo
interesti quatro por ciento LP promos de
tener deficits muy Grande's y hasta on
say por ciento dos a por ciento del p y
so common a doe con la inflation que su
agenor odd o general tambien
hemos tenido Mucha políticas de
repression financière entonces la
combination deficits grandes un sistema
financiero pequeno que no se hace muy
depend ents del finance amento external
nose and how you exploit those in the
shocks que vienen F way but successive
crises and more than a dozen bailouts
from the IMF have made Argentines
doubtful of the government's ability to
break the cycle of economic gloom
[Music]
public agenda percent alumina be a
normal young boy Lucas oh gosh okay I'm
Cassie Tohu we love em we poke a
protective eye we have okay no no no no
sutras atomo Coco sighs okay well do
Chama pull over
well okay pour them less peppiness about
a two hour drive south east of Buenos
Aires has been set by three successive
economic crises one in the 1970s which
led to the closure of its railway
station again in 1989 which was followed
by a near liberal stabilization program
that led to the removal of fuel
subsidies for the town's main employer a
cement factory and the 2001 crisis which
forced the factory's closure I can't
really every time to say see the Haunted
India Sonya slog ammos novecientos la
hora es la miseria me raro in oviya
trabajo no Avia perfect even de nada por
que el pueblo say former el de la
fábrica yeah no estar la fuente de
trabajo principal era cos impossible
claudia diaz co-founded the cooperative
in less peppiness after the cement
factory closed and people were
desperately trying to find a new way of
life no tenemos la colonia de vacaciones
amo en la bandera la bandera de la
fábrica course mr Levangie argentine
vanilla fabric asha no estaba remain t
se sintió mucho la manera Lisa : h eh l
para la escuela la fábrica realmente
comply amok assist NC asociado muna dad
less peppiness isn't the only place
where ordinary Argentines are trying to
fill a void left by what many see as a
failure of the state to manage the
economy and create opportunities in
electro pies por lo que show requires Oh
liudmila momento took our fondo if Elena
said in cycle don't do Larry Sarah Casey
uh Shannon told about pretty ha de la
política father Lorenzo their area open
era todo se s known has been preaching
in these slums for almost 20 years
ya Ali she let me become muniya
is your granny said he misses the video
Sansa Carmelita otros do you proceed Oh
muchos Gracias si si si la VEISHEA show
muchos Nino's
to get the kids here ring Daniel you're
in Treviso Mindy Basara lifts a podium I
see cameras attend Tammy la vita in
conversation tell you Kabakov you a
trained I mean I'll pop up in me a cig I
can be operated she and a mucho Boracay
Linea that the Americans have a total of
socialism publicity La Mesa she now in
Hindi my career of dollar familia
rosamma
come with us now in this year on to
muhammad sorrowful to confess Allah
[Music]
nosotros estamos viendo este situation
todo el tiempo todos los días a a
necesidad de Deonte ahora si lo
Commodore a astana porque necesita a
monopoly national commissary Tom we will
collect clothes and the symbols of the
compromises or give a very impressive
selecting the suitable to suppress or
kill a killer coil is here esta perdido
la mano para todos in ojalá esté place
before a para todo el fin de todos he
became a trabajar para todo komotini
ever the key in it oka so if in the
annual which offices Nikita says
incivility sum up you know a sale and
you can CR see the picked ateva will
team or until a okay you in drag
towing services Shiva I told Nicole Co a
poet urban area social see she's of
course I gotta be
back in the center of Buenos Aires the
message from government officials
contrasts sharply with discontent among
ordinary Argentines but can this
government deliver real change that ends
the cycle of boom and bust Chuck lucky
is the principal diferencia es que esta
vez Atomos radicand hola problemas de la
region Tina sin intentar a Pilar atados
Marcos tenemos que tienen cuenta el
punto de parte de el que somos una kono
Mia a la del mondo sin reservist nd full
tone estado por Vida import our tone
estaba pro do export our donde la carga
in positiva era altissima s trabajo so
yo estamos haciendo Cena Pilar a Paco's
yo creo que eso no yo credo antes en
ninguna experiencia anterior una frases
famosa guy energon Tina's los argentinos
estamos condenado selects ito vara
sentence no me somos de todos naturales
me estamos condenado selects ito me
somos a destiny dosa muna tragedy a poor
algunas de cine oh oh pardon Oh muchos
Argentino trabajamos con la esperanza
syria Magnifico gala tuvimos trabajamos
con la illusion la Esperanza es la
semilla di una fuerza
para hey con un trabajo paciencia
rationally daddy emotionally de
podamos cambiar la cosa lalu she owned a
creer que esto se vedera Fontana meant a
poor acción de algún Milagro no de algún
go Vermont a Luminato
president Macker fiscal discipline is a
novelty in Argentina he signed up to an
unpopular IMF back to austerity drive in
the year before an election and is
aiming to balance the budget by 2019
potentially derail his chances of
remaining in office although he swept to
power on the promise of delivering
change whether his government succeeds
in making Argentina a more stable
country depends on Argentines patience
with those reforms being so Gaeta said
I'll go elastico save me but I still
came in draft Eleonora isso vamos a
seguir Valentino's tenemos que tiene una
speranza porque tenemos un capital umano
important DC mo un capital natural
también la región tina no creo que que
se muy era poured acid on una manera no
porque recurso say en el pais
a gente trabajadora Ayanna's en la gente
Boers area allanté yelp ICM president a
rhombic odd open muchas veces a que hace
nada Wanda odd Oh human tourists siempre
sorry Roland
you
you